[Music]
in kids these days misty space submitted
by tag you're it a fifteen-year-old
youtuber I'm already good has viewers
concern after announcing a pregnancy and
a wedding girl Danielle cone yep what
she called it boom
why should she do what she do she's like
a musically person okay sorry youtuber
of musical ear so she became popular
because of musically and then our
musical we I don't know if I'm saying
right Ziggler's you just showed your age
there I'm [ __ ] old okay and then and
she went to tick tock I guess and then
she has a YouTube with 1.2 million
subscribers why Instagram with 3.5
million followers okay that's just
bigger than JK news oh yeah that's crazy
so I wish I could get a million fans
doing this [ __ ] and lip-sync yeah but
it's like 1.2 million 8 year olds cattle
give a bar are the same that's a [ __ ]
that one day 10 years they're gonna be
18 and then they can vote for me that's
an army that I'm building
mm-hmm but I can't do it now oh god you
just give me like a flashback that
[ __ ] Jake Pollard's are gonna be the
next voters that's we're talking about
my eyes she was like God dead end okay
wait they got married so Danielle is 15
and her boyfriend is 16 where it was
like what he's me what country is she
the same girl who was like a lot of
people were there was controversial
because she was doing that sexy
Halloween costume video but she was
whatever I was [ __ ] when I was 15 and
13 yeah yeah very good sexual younger
and that's why when I stink 15 I'm like
wait I was 15 I felt like pretty grown
at 15
Felton's I'm not like oh my god she's
getting married at 15 I'm more like I
was clubbing if I didn't know I was slow
you were good girl if I yeah I had to be
a good girl but yeah 15 I was like damn
I don't know jack-shit ma'am but is it a
love so like powerful at that age it's
so like all encompassing everything you
are it's like a drug when you're that
young I know that's why I ended up not
saving it till marriage because I was
convinced that I was gonna marry my
boyfriend cuz we were so in love every
girlfriend that I got with I was
convinced I was gonna marry her yeah
that was the stupidest [ __ ] on earth
yeah I don't think you know you're not
like fully developed as your own person
at 19 I was already ready I'm like
alright I already do drugs I have money
we're gonna get married and then we're
gonna we're gonna
that's it why are you so eager to start
like so yeah I know because the [ __ ] to
good ol baby cuz you want to be what I
like move things along like okay well
what's next well what's next like Joe
Josie with said when you're 15 you want
to be 13 when you're 13 you want to be
15 cuz when I was 13 I wanted to be 15
when I wanted 15 I didn't want to be 21
yeah yep that's true would you guys redo
your yes I want a triple down with
everything I was doing and did it even
worse so you would go back if someone
was like OOP I'm a magician fairy I'll
give you back your 13 to 19 you would
redo i would redo it and whatever i was
doing right now I would push things I
did Marder right now so hard at 15 I
would be [ __ ] way more I would not be
going to climb those mistakes is what
makes you crazy
that's how I'm gonna make even more
mistakes do you think they're doing it
for the views they're only doing this
for the view so it did turn out so isn't
that a legal age to marry in some states
tophi this happy baby parents or
anything and you can even think of the
possible
she just looks fat though does she have
a baby oh yeah like me every day
like there's think they're pretending
that they got married in Vegas but
someone pointed out that someone else at
the same location that they say posted
yeah they had this sign that said fake
wedding photos so people are saying like
maybe the offices and so they so
BuzzFeed got in contact with the mom
with antennas Peugeot oh yeah you were
from there right okay so yeah so they
got in contact with her mom and then she
said that the whole like getting married
thing was fake and because they is she
just said she's committed to her best
friend in Vegas legally they can't get
married
Oh what about the baby's action for a
stunt but then when BuzzFeed was asking
about the baby the pregnancy stuff she
would not answer oh we don't know maybe
she's pregnant maybe she is but I don't
think if we don't we don't live in a
time anymore where if you get knocked up
you have to get married right like
people have more choice now there's a
lot of people I meet they go whatever
having a kid I think you're mad oh no I
know people that like our friends that
are having babies together and [ __ ]
that's so crazy what yeah I mean yeah
weird
just to pop a kid out like they want a
kid but they don't want to be married or
have a partner don't you have to be
commanded by be committed to the kid for
at least 18 years yet saying if we got
to be friends for at least eight people
or divorce then [ __ ] hate each other
and raise a kid makes a lot of sense cuz
if you're like best friends are you're
really close right and you're both
single and you both want to have kids
you pop that baby out and you can work
more you know there was this movie that
Madonna was in where she thought that
she got pregnant by her best friend who
was gay and so they ended up like being
together and raising the kids together
but like she would go date guys and he
would go date guys I'd be like for the
kid they were together but then I think
towards the end it turned out that she
ended up having sex with our Warner
boyfriends and then that
dad and then they were fighting in court
to get just sounds dangerous problem the
way I see it is like okay think about it
like an arranged marriage right like
where you might not have romantic
attraction to this person but you're
kind of obligated and it just so happens
that you guys could be good friends and
then so now you prioritize the kid's
life versus a married couple that is so
into their selfish romance that like
it's not about the kid anymore it's
about like well I don't love you like I
used to it's like well you have a
[ __ ] kid now it's true cuz like
people with SEP that are separated like
coming like your situation Isaac goes to
his dad on the weekends it's like you
don't have to be a mom on the weekends
yeah like you get the weekends off
whereas like when you're a married
couple you have to be full time tonight
so Casey yeah like all the time when we
talk about having another kid I'm like
you already know what it's like being a
dad like part time though it's not very
good separate no time no so my son is
from a previous relationship oh so
you're married now and then don't he get
to be a dad part time yeah but he
doesn't know how what it's like to be a
dad yeah and I always thought that
that's such a better idea I mean that's
such a better system because it's like
you get your time off you're like a
habit when you're married you don't ever
get that unless you're away from your
husband which is like if I wanted my
time off I'd want to be with my husband
and grandparents involved like this
weekend and I think you would have been
good parents at 15 and 16 then I would
have been with the gonna be in jail at
15 but like that's a little more girl
like your brain cheese like whining I
was like yeah I think I'd be a better
parent at 50 then now wait fifty or
fifteen team Wow
because you were crazy I don't have
anything to live for so that baby would
have gave me life oh you would have
rejected a lot of [ __ ] that you hadn't
learned about yourself yet on Syria you
would have been so shitty yeah you would
have been fine but your kid would have
been [ __ ] up
you trippin together oh that's true I
wouldn't even feed my dog and I didn't I
wasn't a good doggie dad those TRADOC
you showed me know no one else would
think Oh babies yeah I need some girl in
school that she got pregnant when she
was 14 and I said she had a baby and she
ended up going to a special high school
for moms for pregnant people
yeah pregnant people and then she ended
up having another kid when she was 15 oh
my lord
yeah and then she had another kid when
she was 16 and I'm like stop her [ __ ]
works good huh I mean she's Mexican what
do you think man young and Pope but like
that's just like I feel like that's also
not healthy to be showing their audience
like happening here so they've been
getting so much backlash like how could
you even if this is a prank like what
was this different though from my Kenan
like that MTV show I think the 16 and
pregnant was definitely raw real like
none of those people had money none of
those people were like thriving like
they all had problems they all came from
like a place of less privilege where
these kids have 3 million Instagram
followers they got brand deals they're
doing fine like their kids they're still
kids they don't know they don't know
what they're doing is wrong they don't
know but if they're faking it like they
don't know they just think it's funny
like we're pregnant but let's like fake
it cuz they're like there's still 15
like they still think stupid [ __ ] is
funny the mom got interviewed for
BuzzFeed and she was like as a prank
well the mom likes to capitalize on yeah
I kind of feel like it's just our
culture too because if you think about
most like back in a day people were just
popping out kids at 15 they give you
think of all our grab-grab parents great
grandparents like they look old in their
teens already yeah you look at old
photos on my grandma you still look like
Grandma when you have teens well [ __ ]
and then they already like they speed up
life like there are feel like they're
working yes they're like raising
families and [ __ ] at 20 years old and
kids are being second hearing sexier but
younger y'all gonna make it like that
girl is now 15 I know that's true I bet
you my grandpa's jealous and [ __ ] he's
like dad it looks like she could be 19
yeah
she looks like she could she has a
banker yep didn't listen to her speak to
and she was she's speaking you could
hear how young she is Oh sounds really
young like like the texture of her
voices to vocabulary both do you think
people like that should be ding dong a
YouTube channel if they do dumb [ __ ]
oh no cuz they're not hurting anybody
but them sell it's also like freedom of
freedom of speech and like freedom of
expression parenting should step in and
you should monitor what the [ __ ] your
kids watch it sounds like them because
you don't want to put the responsibility
on it yeah they're doing some choices
but I mean don't you think with like
smartphones now how are you supposed to
monitor and give them one like 13 like
you need a phone still say you ain't you
can't have a YouTube channel where
you're like doing this there's but what
they watch where my parents monitored
the [ __ ] out of everything I did really
yeah I mean I hated them then but like
like I grew up a lot slower than the
rest of the people in my neighborhood I
feel like once we had like Internet and
computer and you give them your own [ __ ]
like you can't control like how do you
know that they don't get like and some
weird deep red it threatened like join
Isis like you just wouldn't know cuz
they could hide that [ __ ] from me that's
true
I was in kind of an M&M board cult I
believe it I give our address out
because I thought I was in love with
this guy yeah I gotten so much but I was
so I was I was 14 I was 14 and I thought
I was in love with this guy that would
men the M&M board chat we had bits how
old was he he was 18 so he says yeah no
he said he was 16 and then I found out
later that he was 18 and then you found
out later he's 50 why would you lower
your age that's a complete loser right
what yeah and I think I might have lied
about being 60 so we thought we were
both say we were 16
dude I would always say when I was 13 I
would say I was 16 - cuz I'm like 16
just sounds like y'all ever heard of a
butt whistle no what is that
nevermind but was
I my friend has a baby was teaching me
about it we're like you stick it in the
baby's butt when they have gas real bad
and it's like this long you don't stick
the whole thing in but you like put it
in the opening of their butt and then it
lets the air come out it's like it is I
love what was all that for bait what
made you think of that yeah what were we
just started fishing we were talking
about something I was over here I see
sorry I don't mean you Dara
so off-track no it's okay does it all
the time that was like a joke that
wasn't I have to doing nothing you did
it for me sorry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]